(upbeat piano music)
(audience applause and cheering)
- All right, all right.
Can anybody prove the TSA is
actually doing a good job?
We don't know who to
write to, they're like,
you know, they're hall monitors, right?
Like we get that, right?
They have no real jurisdiction at all.
There was a segment I saw
on the news, they said that
more TSA agents have been
caught trying to steal stuff
than there have been people caught trying
to smuggle stuff on the planes.
That's real.
I said that, and one night,
there was a TSA agent
in the audience, and he
came up to me, he's like,
"Hey, man, I wanna let
you know, ever since TSA's
"been implemented, planes
don't get hijacked anymore
so whatta ya got to say about that?"
I was like yeah, true,
but now planes disappear.
(audience laughter)
I love gettin' older, I'm
probably the oldest person
in this show.
That's kinda cool.
See, but in L.A., in
L.A. when you get older,
when you get like 30 and
above, they make you feel
like you're a dinosaur
and you're dying, you know
what I'm saying, that's what they do.
That's not true.
In fact, I figured it out.
If you're 29 and above,
you've lived a great life,
you've seen a lot of great shit happen.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if you thought of all
the stuff that you've seen
if you're 29 and above?
We saw Jordan and Kobe
play in their prime.
We were around for Tupac and Big.
You realize that?
We survived two Bush
presidencies, do you realize that?
Two of 'em, dos, you get that?
Two!
We saw the internet get created, right?
And now I'm supposed to
feel stupid 'cause some
22 year old kid figures
out Snapchat before I do,
that's what I'm supposed
to feel bad about?
I'm supposed to feel dumb?
I never know what the
hell they're doing, is it
a video or a picture, they'd be like,
"Yo Q, come get in the Snap!"
I'm like, yo, shoutout,
we here at BuzzFeed,
it's goin' down, baby, they were like,
"Dude, we're taking a picture, man,"
I'm like, you shoulda said
something then, I don't know
what you expected from me.
Yeah, you ever realize how
protective we are of our phones?
Like we are too attached
to our phones, right?
I think we can all agree that, right?
Like, we could hear a
phone drop right now,
everyone's gonna be like,
oh my God, is it okay?
That sound like the screen
shattered, oh my God.
Oh, it was just a Droid? Okay.
Okay, nobody cares, nobody cares.
We'd hear a baby drop,
and they'd be crying,
and we're like, that was a
dumb baby, someone should've
held that baby, I don't know
why anyone would think that.
(audience laughter)
Like, you know when you go
to, you go to try and like
show someone your phone,
you give them their phone,
and there's that knee-jerk
reaction to snatch it back,
you're like don't, don't
touch, just, okay, just,
no just look a little
bit, please, okay no,
okay here you go, no seriously look.
Okay, look at this picture,
look at this picture,
look at this picture and
you give 'em the phone,
they've earned your trust,
and they start swiping and you're like,
what the fuck are you
doing, dude, I will break
your fuckin' finger, you fuck...
It's not fuckin' Tinder,
dawg, don't swipe!
What are you doing, just
look, it's your fuckin eyes,
man, that's all you gotta
do, you had one job,
motherfucker, don't swipe!
Do you guys store numbers
in your phone immediately
when you get it?
I don't, I'm like, I have to text you
for three weeks, right, I have
to text you for three weeks
like daily for me to
be like you know what?
I think this person's gonna be in my life
for a little bit now,
you know what I'm saying
I think I'm keeping this
person here, good job.
- Quincy!
- What's up, buddy, what's going on?
- What's going on, man, how you been?
- I'm good, baby, how are you?
- Man, great, I'm seeing
you randomly on the street.
- I know, I was just chillin', man.
- Dude, you are on fire right now.
- Man, I'm just trying-
- On fire!
- I'm trying, man, I'm trying!
- (Laughs) It's crazy.
- It is, man.
Well, it was good seeing you, man-
- Yeah, yeah, for sure-
- I'm gonna get on outta here, man.
- Listen, man!
- What's up, playa?
- We should probably do lunch,
how do you feel about that?
- I would love to have
lunch with you, man.
- Stop it, are you serious?
- Yeah, yeah.
- OH! OH!
- What, what, what, what?
Did you rip something, what happened?
- Guess what, dawg?
- What, what, what, what, what?
- I'm throwing a party this Friday
- Okay, okay.
- At the crib
- Right.
- I need you to come.
- Man, this Friday?
- This Friday!
- Nooooo, Friday?
- You gotta come, dawg,
you gotta come
- Dude, yes, yes, I'm down!
- Are you serious
- You ain't gotta tell
me twice, I'm there.
- Really? Stop it.
- Why would I lie to you, it's not a game.
- Okay, great.
- You got my information, text me up, man.
- Yeah yeah yeah, I'll text you right now.
- You got my number?
- I will send you the details right now
- Text me, man.
- If it's the same number
- The same number.
- Thank you so much!
- Sweet, man.
- Good, no problem, man.
- It's so good to see you!
- Ima catch up with you man
- Great, great.
- You hit me up, playa.
- And by the way, hey, maybe
sometime we could do dinner
or something.
- Yeah man, I'm down.
- Yeah, that'd be great!
- What do you like to eat?
- I literally eat everything.
- Okay, all right, man, cool.
- Cool, cool, cool.
- All right, man.
- Whatever you want.
- Salad.
- A salad is great! Greenery.
- Sweet.
- I eat salad now, look at this!
- Oh, what? That's crazy!
- (mumbling with mouth full)
(laughs)
- I can't wait.
I'll catch you, playa.
- Okay, man.
That's motherfuckin' Quincy Jones, y'all.
Quincy is here.
(chill music)
- That's why I didn't save
your number, bitch ass.
Not all men cheat, but all
men struggle with cheating.
See, women know how to be
faithful 'cause they've been
turning down dick their whole life.
Whole life, all it is is
like friendzone, friendzone,
I'll fuck you, you're my
boyfriend, I hate you,
help me move, pick me up from the airport,
that's what it is, that's...
That's what it's like.
So you guys know how
to be faithful, right?
Women know how to be faithful.
I could barely turn down Costco
samples, you realize that?
There's no way on God's Earth
I could ever turn down sex.
(audience laughter)
Okay, I got a few more, then
I'm gonna get on outta here.
(audience laughter)
I think they're good, but
you guys may not like 'em.
But we'll try, we'll see what's up.
Did you plug your ears?
She's like, "I don't
wanna hear anything bad.
"I only want happy jokes like TSA."
You can tell a lot about
a person by their tattoos.
I have a lot of tattoos,
I have 35 tattoos.
I know.
I have 35 tattoos and I could
tell a lot about a person
by their tattoos, right?
Like, for example, someone
has like a bible verse,
or prayer hands tattooed
on them, I know for a fact
they've been to prison,
you know what I'm saying,
I think that's a safe
assumption, I think we're all
in the pocket with that one, right?
Or someone like looks Hispanic
or has an Asian last name
and a koi fish tattoo,
they're Filipino, right?
We can all agree on that, right?
And if you don't know what a
Filipino is, you're racist.
All right, we can all agree on that one.
I figured out why we go to war.
You know America's been
at war for like 93 percent
of its existence, right?
I think we've been around
for like 300 years,
we've been at war for like, 290 of them
or something like that, right?
That's crazy, right?
You know why we go to war?
The bitches, that's why we go to war.
We go to war for the women,
that's why we've been
in the Middle East for
so long, that's why...
Too soon? Okay.
I'm gonna try and deliver
this joke again, from the top.
Guys, I know why we (laughs)
(audience laughter)
Guys, I know why we go to war.
Know why we go to war?
Cause the pres (laughs)
The saddest "why..."
We go to war because the
presidents have a thing
for women in their country,
right, that's why we've
been in the Middle East for so long.
Bush had a thing for Middle
Eastern women, right,
there was no oil, there was no
weapons of mass destruction.
Have you seen Muslim porn?
Yeah, that's why we're
there, that's the catch.
(female outraged noises)
(audience laughter)
I'm shooting 90 percent from
the field, I do one joke
where I fly too close to the
sun, you guys get sensitive?
Okay, okay. All right.
That was a great joke,
nobody was harmed in
the making of that joke.
- I'm not Muslim.
- Okay, what are you talking about?
- I'm actually Christian.
- But what does that
have to do with me asking
do you want fish or pork?
- Well, are you asking me
that because you thought
I was Muslim?
- No, I was asking you that
because that's what the menu's
broken down as, and I wanted
fish, so I asked if you wanted
- Oh, oh my God, I am so sorry.
- Hey, it's okay, I just
wanted to make sure we're
on the same page here, you know?
- Yeah, I'm just like, really on edge.
- Yeah, what happened, tell me about it.
- Earlier, on the train,
somebody basically thought
it would be like a funny joke
to say that I had a bomb.
- You're kidding me, right?
- I couldn't believe it,
it was so rude, and a very
old school insult.
It was just so offensive,
because it was so juvenile.
- It was juvenile, it wasn't
funny, it was rude, it
had no originality, tons of
things definitely wrong there.
- Yeah, well.
- I mean, you could've at
least made it clever, you know.
I mean, if he had been clever,
I feel like it would have
made it a little more
digestible, you know?
- No, it's still offensive,
I still would've been mad.
- I feel like if the Richard
Pryor of the train had
said that, you probably would've laughed.
- Uh, no.
- Okay, lemme explain.
Richard Pryor specialized
in racial humor, so,
if Richard Pryor himself
had came back from the dead
and been in that train, or the
Richard Pryor of that train
had been on there, I really
feel like, 99 percent,
you would have laughed.
- Unbelievable.
- Wait, where you going?
- My mother told me never
to date a black comic.
- Where you going, that...
That was racist.
- I thought it was funny.
- You guys like rap music?
(audience laughter)
I love rap music, and when I was...
See, I'm older, and so
when I was growing up,
rap music inspired you, it
motivated you to do shit,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, 'cause I grew up with
Biggie's "Juicy" on the radio,
I grew up with Tupac's "Keep
Ya Head Up" on the radio,
you know what I'm saying?
I grew up with DMX...
(audience laughter)
Okay, it was a tough sophomore
year, but you get the gist,
like, I grew up with, he made good songs.
And now, rap music is
just verbally abusive,
you know what I'm saying,
just a bunch of mean-spirited
rappers talking shit to me, you know?
Like I was in an Uber on
the way over here, I'm just
bragging now, and I was in
the Uber on the way over here
and the beat stops, and
the last lyrics are,
"Yeah, you a bitch if you
don't have a hundred thousand
dollars in your bank account."
I was like...
That is it, I've had it
up to here, I'm good.
I'm working two jobs, and
I'd appreciate it if he
appreciated my work ethic a little more.
Furthermore, who keeps a
hundred thousand dollars
in your bank account, that's
financially irresponsible,
we all know that.
Get a CD or a IRA, everybody
knows that's so much smarter.
(audience laughter)
Fuck you, rapper.
Then rappers are always
talking about how they could
take my bitch, all the time.
They're like, "ha ha, don't
bring a bitch to BuzzFeed,
"I'll take yo bitch, ha ha ha ha!"
I'll be like, ha ha ha ha, please don't.
Please don't take my bitch.
I love her, and we've been
together three months.
Three years, three years (laughs)
And one of those years was long distance.
You got your own money, why
don't you get your own bitch?
(audience laughter)
Kinda mean-spirited to
take someone else's bitch
without permission, right?
Fuck you, rapper.
(audience laughter)
(club music)
- Hi.
What?
- It's just that when I
said hi, you said hi back,
and I thought it was
going differently, but
my name's Quincy.
- Hi, I'm Nyla, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
I see you've got some moves
there, look at you little mama!
Lemme show you how we do
it like that right there.
- Please, you ain't about
shit with them cookout arms.
- (Laughs) Hey, man, you're
cool, can I buy you a drink?
- What?
- I said, can I buy you a...
- Nyla, those guys over there got a table.
They want us to come sit with them.
- Oooh, nice! It was nice meeting you.
- Hey, can I have your number?
- Nice meeting you too!
(ladies whooping)
- Hey, what's up ladies, how we doin?
- [Ladies] Good!
- [VIP Guys] All right,
who wants some shots?
(VIP group celebrating)
- You think any other
genre music does this shit
to their fans, though?
Think Blake Shelton talks shit
to his fan base like that?
Yeah, you a bitch if you don't
have a F-250 pickup truck.
Whoa, Blake, you need
to calm down, brother,
you need to calm down, you're
about to lose some of that
Voice money you keep talking like that.
All right, well...
(audience laughter)
I was great, you know what I'm
saying, I just have to say,
like, if you didn't like
that, that president war joke,
then Google some shit 'cause
the world is crazy, okay?
Thank you, goodnight.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(upbeat piano music)